le confinement donne visiblement très
fin aux français la preuve en est ils
étaient hier soir très nombreux devant
m6 qui diffusait top chef avec trois
millions cinq cent mille téléspectateurs
le programme se paye même le luxe de
battre son record depuis 2015 c'est
juste une merveille un épisode avec un
philippe etchebest toujours stricte avec
ses apprentis mais qu'est ce que tu as
mis dedans que les bus de la coriandre
ya des coriaces que c'est du cerfeuil
nasa pardon de la nuit certains mais qui
sait aussi rester un sacré déconneur
épreuve de pâtisserie quand on est
amateur c'est pas de la tarte
sacré de filou le thème de la semaine
tourner autour du japon avec ses fameux
ninja
enjoy
mais aussi avec ses plats typiques
saupoudré de ces petite imitation un
numéro de top chef particulièrement
gourmands et gourmandes gourmandise
gourmandise une émission qui tout comme
the voice a aussi ses auditions à
l'aveuglé sauf que là on auditionne pas
les chanteurs mais les huîtres le seul
point commun ce sont les casseroles une
dégustation éliminatoires qui aura causé
l'élimination de justin justin ça veut
dire que c'est terminé pour vous mais
l'essentiel c'est de participer à les
intégrer aux gars comme pour les vaches
alors les chérit le hier à la télé ça
rendez-vous vous adorez 1 dans tes
peines peut on le fait dans ce soir
shebab à eric naulleau il n'a pas payé
est resté chez lui ou quoi classé site
ap ap photo lui dire voilà c'est une
barque à le mecque de thaï nguyên ça au
mieux le cas alors les séries qu'elle se
calme à top chef on a des bonnes notes
on a des moins bonnes notes top chef
alors juste sauf si vous mettez 8 sur 10
à top chef
moi j'ai adoré top chef il ya
franchement c'est une émission que je
regarde tout le temps que j'adore
vraiment et en plus lui zine moi même il
y avait une astuce hier qui a été donnée
par un candidat que j'aime beaucoup
s'appelle maurice qui est extrêmement
créatif et en fait pour que les pommes
de terre soient très joli très ronde est
très homogène il les brosses avec le
côté vert de l'eponge d'accord pas mal
ça c'est génial là il ya une petite
astuce vous aimez 8 sur d'autres atomes
chef
elle a adoré topchef alors vous le rend
ça y est vous avez mis combien lui aussi
pourquoi moi je trouve ça génial parce
que pendant le confinement c'est
tellement galère que la cuisine reprend
sa place et je trouve que l'édition
encore plus d'intérêt et en plus il y
avait un dessert sans sucre donc je
trouve ça très bien et voilà je trouve
que c'est hyper utile en ce moment de
regarder ce type d'émission et de
faramineux alors on revienne candidat
qui a fait beaucoup réagir mon programme
c'est justin justin
au point du sind va la scène jeune
candidate de 27 ans qui n'a pas laissé
insensible les téléspectateurs faut dire
qu elle l avait la joie de vivre est là
elle qui voit là elle est contente
d'être là elle souriait tout en
regardant rapidement qu'il allait un peu
de yoga comme pour les vaches pour être
en osmose avec mon opinion sur la
poitrine
c'est et tout mélanger c'est un bolide
dit pulga le plein d'émotions qu'il faut
gérer
tu sais moi je fais partie des huîtres
dernier les huîtres dernier à huîtres
derniers mondiaux voit donc m6 qui est
arrivé en tête des audiences est top
chef hier eric naulleau top 7 vous avez
mis combien vous avez qui fait ou pas
moi j'ai mis huit g8 parce que c'est un
miracle je ne sais rien faire en cuisine
la nourriture ça ne m'intéresse pas -
bon repas sains sandwich mix avec un
café en lisant l'équipe et ça me
passionne pourtant donc c'est une super
bonne émission
même ceux qui s'intéressent pas à la
bouche sont scotchés et moi j'aime bien
il faut faire tout cela avec des huîtres
gilles verdez bienne-nidau en fait
l'émission d'hier a profondément déplu
tout était organisé
mise en scène pour que justin soient
éliminés les uns ont été faites pour
qu'elles faire on voulait la faire
sortir
c'est l'une des deux seules jeune femme
c'est elle qui était la plus
charismatique elle dérangeait on l'a
viré je suis très choqué vous êtes très
choquée bas ça se voit oui mais comment
vous l'avez dit donc justin s'est fait
éliminer n'importe quand et n'importe
quoi garder son élimination regarder
[Musique]
mes sentiments chef premières
impressions alors on est jeune et
préparation radicalement différente
on a en tout cas trois niveaux dans la
dégustation afin d'atteindre 8 remet
dans la longueur en bouche si finalement
litres qui persistent
je vais prendre un litre numéro un
qui a fait ça c'est mourir et donc
justin ça veut dire que c'est terminé
pour vous après cette sixième semaine du
concours comme ça qui vous qu'est ce que
vous retenez de ces deux semaines moi
j'ai vécu maurice
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment vécu mon rêve et je suis
trop contente j'ai rien lâché jusqu'au
bout
donc voila moi j'ai rien à regretter
j'ai tout gagné
voilà c'est difficile de partir j'aurais
voulu continuer c'est sûr mais cette
expérience elle m'a bouleversé alors
castaldi base avant mon chéri combattent
amiens bat givi trois mois mais tout ça
bien produit vous savez moi moi la
cuisine quand je goûte pas excusez moi
ça ne m'intéresse pas en argument je
vois je te vois j'apprécie groupe accor
vient des tur garde d'un défi mx1 web
est bel et bien justement c'est quelque
chose devant les films x
voilà quelle heure un gala bah oui bah
oui on aime pas ça ils aiment pas l'acte
et j'ai jamais la télé elle éleva qu
elle était franchement ça m'intéresse
pas tous les deux ils pas tous pas tous
à dire qu'en moyenne candidate jeune
charismatique et belges ont comblé les
mines auraient connu la télé 50 principe
à une bonne combien tu des limites c'est
aussi bien connu s'est vraiment passé de
travers de monsieur naulleau vous parler
autrement je ne peux décrire à quel vous
foutez débarque dans vos émissions là
d'accord c'est simplement ça vous ferait
du bien de ce ver 2 dont prendre une de
20 ans ok donc vous êtes vous dit rien à
coire et justine elle dérangeait justine
elle dérange qui nourrit mais celle ci
est si naulleau était rangée on la vire
et ça dérange personne
pas du tout alors tout fait pour la
virer il y en a il y en a un qui est en
galère hier c'est gratien c'est un
candidat qui appartient la brigade de
philippe etchebest est dû à plusieurs
reprises il a été en gros stade à se
regarder je connais ça gémit il ya
quatre feuilles dedans
il ya déjà quelques noms et enfin la
passe et je remets tout en dessous de
100 des trucs et des dans l'eau froide
[Musique]
j'ai pris du céleri branche parce que
c'est très frais voilà avoir ce côté
fraîcheur herbacées je vais jouer sur
trois aujourd'hui
[Musique]
merde j'ai bloqué la truck
comment ça marche
comme ce que c'était
[ __ ] mais qu'est ce que tu as mis
dedans les bus de la coriandre
il ya d'accord non c'est du sérieux
pardon de lui s'affrontaient alors j'ai
une bonne nouvelle
j'ai des nouvelles de jean michel maire
par sms qui prend plus la défense d'eric
naulleau
et qui dit à gilles verdez elle est
charismatique donc on s'est arrangé pour
la gérer elle est où la logique de
gilles verdez voilà jean michel aulas
voilà ce qu'est ce que vous répondez
mais elle m'a elle a mangé boucher
d'huîtres est le chef qui était son chef
là comme par hasard virée sur une bouche
et d'huîtres
mais jean-michel à être aux métaux
exécute quand tu veux d'accord les tanks
à 3 mais moi ce que tu dis sur deux et
des branchements alors tu sais tout le
monde tant par as tout le monde hier la
brigade relève d'art aux attentes et un
petit délire ils ont tous nous aider
bandeau rouge autour de leurs têtes sans
rigoler chirurgie avait à présent que
j'étais donc que l'on tape à top chef y
avait un truc
[Musique]
sans déconner du cru qu'ils avaient
denis brogniart qu'elle arrivait à
bonbons stade 24 chefs est arrivé
premier des audiences et je suis très
heureux pour m6 voilà voilà que
j'embrasse son bras sport mon ami
stéphane rotenberg est mon ami également
nicolas de tavernost le président de m6
que à qui je fais un gros bisou